This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, after the love and the enthusiasm that I received for our psychology of fashion episode and our psychology of personal style episode, so many of you demanded an episode specifically on micro trends. So many of you in my DMs being like, that part of the podcast was great. Can you do
a full episode on it? And I thought that this week, we would. Micro Trends have flooded our feeds recently. I just feel like the internet cannot go more than a few weeks without circulating like the new it fashion trend, the new it top, the new it print. And I also think nearly every single one of us at some stage has participated. I bought a lubbu last year. I have to admit it. I currently have a pair of office siren glasses that you guys are never going to see that are, they are incredibly impractical considering I actually wear glasses. And they are so small and they are so tiny and that is a discussion for a whole other time. The question really is, despite the fact that we know it's marketing, despite the fact that we know these trends,
aren't going to last more than a year, maybe a few months. Why do we participate in microtrends? Particularly in our 20s, what is the pool, what is the drive, especially when things do tend to be cheap and poorly made and, you know, break after a couple of words. Would you believe me if I told you it all came down to human psychology? I think you probably would, especially since this is a psychology podcast, but microchens especially, the way they influence human emotion and human behavior, that is why they are so hard to escape and so hard to kind of walk away from. So today we are going to break it all down from the role of dopamine to social contagion, our nervous system, frontal lobe development, identity politics. They all have some
role to play in this as you will soon be aware. So if in the past year, the past couple of years, you found yourself suddenly wanting to buy animal prints or an impractical shoe or an impractical bag or trinket, this episode is hopefully going to give you some answers. And it's not going to shame you from buying those things if they bring you joy. It's just going to explain the psychology behind why you want to buy them. So without further ado, let's get into. the psychology of microtrends. To begin to really understand the emotions and the psychology behind all of this, let's start by talking about what a trend actually is and what a micro trend actually is within that space. So in general, when we traditionally refer to trends, we are
talking about a sustained change in preferences that represents, often represents, I should say, some larger social, political, aesthetic, technological shift or advancement in society. To qualify as a trend, something, whether it's a style, whether it's music, it needs to show direction, i.e. it's different on you from what we had before. It needs to show duration. So it's persisting over a meaningful period of time, whether that's a few weeks, months, or years. It needs to show scale as well. So basically, enough people are buying it, consuming it, making it so that it becomes a recognizable part of our broader social world. We can see that particularly, somebody was saying this to me the other day, with jeans and gene trends and how things have changed over the
years. So skinny jeans in the 90s and 2000s when like extreme thinness was really chic, flared jeans in the 70s and 80s when dance and music and grooving and moving. was like the big thing. Wide leg jeans in the past decade, which shows like a movement towards comfort and away from restriction. That's like a great example of how trends match what's going on in society. And the thing is they can last decades, like the active, casual, at leisure wear trend we're still seeing right now, that is a trend that is probably going to stay for a long time or women wearing pants. At some point that was a trend. Now it's just part of the culture. Now it's just a dominant way that we see fashion. So again, a few seasons or a few years or life-changing
or throughout our entire lives, like all of those things can be trends. Unlike though, major trends which sizably push fashion in a new direction, like the women wearing pants thing or the, you know, athletic wearers clothes or casual clothes thing, micro trends are short-lived, they are niche, they are forgotten about very quickly, and they are overwhelmingly driven by social media. Like social media trends, you know, they inflate really fast as everyone wants to get on board and everybody wants to make money, everybody wants to be seen as cool, and then the next thing comes along and they get dropped very quickly. Micro trends like social media trends, only last as long as our attention does. And in this day and age, where we expect to be constantly
entertained, that is not very long. That is why the micro-trend has become so big over the past few years. Here is where the academia comes in. Researchers who study fashion psychology have found that the life cycle of any fashion trend that you can think of, whether it is cow print, skinny jeans, ballet flats, cottage core, whatever. Every trend can be divided into five stages. Introduction, rise, peak, decline, and obsolescence. Okay, so let's track this cycle for a second. Beginning with introduction, this is when a trend emerges, maybe from a runway, from a celebrity, from a cultural or grassroots style bloke core. This was a recent one that was inspired by like 90s British football culture that was then kind of,
have made more publicly accessible. Corp Corps, inspired by outdoor hikers and their expensive gear. Normally there is like an influential moment or an influential celebrity or something that people grab onto, that people suddenly become like anammed by. And the trend has always been there, albeit not trendy in the initial kind of group that created it. But suddenly it gets taken out of that small, microcosm or that small environment and made global, national, made kind of cultural.
At this point, experimental people are testing it. Major retailers aren't yet willing to take a gamble on it. They aren't yet mass producing it because they're just still not sure if it's going to catch on. Then there becomes a rise period. At some stage, the trend gains visibility. It gains traction. This is when we start seeing paid promotions, stylists. more celebrities, influences kind of wearing it.
There's often, again, some spark moment, you know, often driven by something that's happening online or driven by like a trend conscious individual. And now we're at the point where it slowly trickled down from more experimental individuals into more and two more general consumers because main brand or, you know, widely accessible clothing brands have started to make it cheaper or make it in more variance. The peak is when the momentum is at its highest. Items are widely, widely available across many major retailers. It is being embraced by maybe a majority.
The rise of Sambas back in 2022, 2022, 2023, this is a great example. This moment of a trend peaking can last. a while, but often it will quickly fade. And that's when we move into decline. After the peak, there does come a point of oversatuation, you know, it's not cool anymore because everybody's doing it. So celebrities move on, influences, stylists, the average person kind of starts to move on, maybe not the average person, but the person who always wants to be ahead of the, of the majority starts to move on. And the consumer kind of gets tired of it. They're kind of like, I've seen this before. So brands start to phase it out. They discount the remaining stock.
The decline stage often for the case of microtrends really quickly follows the peak stage. As soon as you see that a trend is extremely widespread and popular, you can kind of guess it's going to start declining pretty soon because, yes, people want to be part of the in group, but they also don't want to be in the in group that everybody else is in. So if everybody is wearing it, they're kind of like, well, how am I? standing out. This is when we get to obsolescence. Nobody wants to wear it anymore. It's not considered current, but as is often, I think becoming more common, the trend may actually reappear again in a reinterpreted form, even years, decades down the line. So we still might
see the bubble come up again. And also, the people who were originally authentically wearing these items because they weren't a trend to them, they are also going to keep wearing them. You know, they're going to keep participating. Because again, it was never about looking cool or fitting in. They just liked the item. You know, your dad still buys his new balance 530s, right? Whether the fashion girl is wearing them or not. So there is still this core, this core loyal group of people who have won this trend before
and will continue to wear it afterwards. Again, think about any trend you can imagine. Almost every single one of them will follow the same five-stage pattern. The thing is, though, most trends nowadays, like in the past, the pattern and the cycle used to take five, 10, 15 years. Social media, fast fashion, has drastically condensed this timeline, meaning the gap between introduction and overhauling. oversaturation could literally be a few months, like with Labuboos, for example. Something could start trending on Monday. Like this coming Monday, a new trend could pop up.
By Friday, Amazon, Sheehan, Zara could be shipping out the first prototypes of that trend, because that's how fast they operate these days. That means, you know, what's cool can never really be cool for too long, because part of what makes trends last is the aura of inaccessibility and originality. But because everything is accessible these days, trends, again, are condensed. Honestly, whilst I was researching this episode, I was looking into companies like Sheen and like Amazon and like Al-Zaras. And the stuff that I found like blew my mind. I honestly thought that I was pretty informed about fast fashion. but the scale of these companies and their production and their output is just like off the charts.
It's almost unbelievable. Companies like these have perfected the production model and the pipeline to production because everything is done in one factory these days. Everything from research to design to fabric production to garment production to shipping all comes out of one big industrial complex. meaning, again, something could trend. They could have a product that replicates that trend within 48 hours and they can make it even cheaper in the next 48 hours and ship it out
because that's their business model. Their business model focuses on quantity and replication rather than quality. According to data collected by this nonprofit called Rest of World, between July and December of 2021, Sheehan alone added anywhere between, and I need you to be prepared for this. Are you ready? 2,000 and 10,000 new styles to its app every single day. Day, every day. Anything that trends, regardless of intellectual property, regardless of material, they can make a dupe,
and they can advertise the dupe, before they even have the resources to make it, because that's a way of them gauging interest. They have an entire market research team, an entire data team that tracks what is selling online for other companies and then compares that against their own sale data to determine what items are going to be hits, what items are going to be misses,
what they should plan for, what they should create. So basically they can create an order inventory virtually on demand. It's easy to see how microtrends fit into this, right? I feel like I don't need to go into it any further, but I think it's really important to see the system that is like happening below the surface of our everyday consumer choices. So that's like, that's what's going on globally in in terms of the market. What is going on in terms of our minds? When trends are rising, peaking, falling. Why do we feel pulled into this cycle? At first glance, it might look really random.
Maybe it looks like a big coincidence, but in reality, there is a major undercurrent of human psychology at play. Behind every trend lies the psychological concept of social proof. And this is the idea that essentially, in everything we do, we look to others to guide our behavior, especially when we are not sure. Trends, trends give us a shorthand, mental and emotional code for what is going to give us acceptance. And again, what will give us access to the in-group of the time or the people, what will give us access to the people who we desire to be more like or we desire to surround ourselves with? If the cool girls are wearing baggy jeans, your mind says, well, if I wear baggy jeans, I will be a cool girl. I will have the uniform of a cool girl. It makes that mental shortcut.
That is why so many trends are driven by celebrities, influences, people we see online, because why would we follow these people in the first place if a small part of us didn't want to be like them? Or if some small part of us didn't feel some kind of allegiance to these individuals. It's extremely compelling. And when you are bombarded with potentially dozens of examples of people following the trend every single day, the pressure to conform becomes a lot stronger. So, so strong, so powerful. Let's break this down a little bit further. There are actually a few distinct psychological processes that are going on at this very point in your mind that determine whether you are going to adopt the next trend you see on your timeline or not.
The first is how susceptible you are to something that we call social contagion. So basically, if you are closer to somebody, and not just physically, but if you are closer to somebody in terms of age, in terms of whether you admire them or not, your proximity is going to determine whether you pick up the trend. So basically, social contagion is this like rapid, unconscious spread of emotions, spread of behaviors, spread of beliefs that kind of ripples through a group or network. The way trends spread is often described as functioning kind of like an
infectious disease, you know, passing between individual to individual. One person adopts a trend, then the three people closest to them adopt the trend, then the people who follow them online, adopt the trend. It's literally like, it's like an airborne virus. You are more susceptible. You are more susceptible to social contagion, the closer you are to the source. Again, not just physically, but emotionally. Like, the more you feel a sense of similarity or allegiance to the person who is an initial adopter of a trend, the more you are going to buy into it. Also something to note, you know, the more a trend spreads as well, the more it mutates like a virus. And the more it becomes more popular to broader groups of people because companies know that
if they want to make money, they have to adapt a trend to more and more social groups. They have to initiate buy-in from more and more distinct subgenres. So they make it available in new countries, they make it available in new colorways, until it reaches like the highest status a trend can reach, which is that it becomes a must-have. The ultimate goal of a brand is essentially to be able to access all different subgroups of society through social contagion by providing a version everyone can relate to. I feel like the Adidas Sambas are a great example of how efficiently Adidas was able to do this. If you think about the Sambas or the gazelles or whatever they were, like, by their peak,
I swear they were in every color, every type of style, there were bows, there were chains attached to them, there were different fabrics. This is a prime example of how marketers use social contagion to their advantage to make the virus, of a micro trend, I guess more infectious to as many people as possible. Next, during this process, we are of course also feeling the pull of social conformity. This is a process whereby we align our attitudes, our beliefs, our behaviors to fit in to the social majority or the people that we see as the social majority. And by doing that reducing uncertainty, our fear of missing out combined with the illusion of scarcity.
So things like limited item drops, limited time to bag a trend before saturation hits, means that we are so bought in to seeing trends as a form of social currency. We are so brought into feeling like, if I buy this item, I'm going to be accepted. And if I don't, there is this real emotional drop of like, I don't know, like social rejection. Don't feel worried or ashamed if you've done this. We all have.
And we all will probably continue to do so because it is hardwired in you to want to conform and to always want to be close to the thing that is most accepted or most popular in society. There was a 2015 study from researchers at Stanford and also researchers in the Netherlands, actually, it was a collaboration. And it basically showed the primal neurological reactions we have. have when conforming. It, like conforming, whether it's through fashion, through music, through behavior, is a incredibly addictive and powerful form of positive reinforcement learning. And it initiates all kinds of like positive emotions and happy emotions that make us want to continue
doing so. So that is the first explanation for the like proliferation of micro trends. It's all social. It's all about wanting to belong. There is also a biological lens to this as well. Believe it or not, what you buy is often ruled by the tiniest chemicals inside your brain, which we are going to explore together after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you
hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new
season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Whilst the desire for social acceptance definitely drives us towards micro-trans, right? There is another big driver at play, and that is dopamine culture. dopamine culture, the rush that we get when we browse, when we click, when we buy, when we have our purchase, you know, turn up at our door.
It feels like a sense of approval and it activates something really ancient and primal in us. That is the desire to hunt, to gather, to receive, to basically like feel proud of our capture, feel proud of our resource. microtrends activate dopamine in so many ways through novelty, through this anticipation cycle, because there's always going to be something better or newer for us to wear, through just the act of spending money. Spending money gives us dopamine. A lot of it also comes down to our attention and the use of shopping as entertainment. Our attention, you know, especially in the context of microtrendes, is kind of.
What catches your attention online in the real world is what releases dopamine. When something no longer captures our attention, the dopamine levels drop. We go searching for our next hit. Over time, it can, and it does create an addictive feedback loop that fuels microtrends because we are looking for something to basically keep us entertained and excited at all times. our brain wants that so badly. It is hungering for it. Micro trends as well represent something more than just clothes, right? Scrolling your feed for the next thing, buying an outfit, trying it on days later is a form of short-term entertainment and gratification. It is all part of a scientifically
engineered dopamine feedback loop that wants you to, wants you to prioritize being happy fast, and wants you to prioritize getting what you want quickly over long-term gratification. This is a much broader societal shift, as I'm sure a lot of you guys are thinking. We can see this pattern everywhere, literally everywhere. Instead of reading a newspaper, you know, we watch a 30-second hot take online. Instead of consuming two hours of poetry or stand-up comedy, we watch one viral moment. Instead of listening to an album, we enjoy the snippet of one song on TikTok. Everything needs to provide instant gratification as quickly as possible.
And microtrans again are no different. Instead of buying clothes less often, instead of developing a unique sense of style, instead of really like hunting for quality pieces, instead of literally making our clothes. Right. Now, this is just another form of quick entertainment for us to consume. What's more, I think brands know this. They definitely know this. One study called an economic perspective on attention or something like that. This study basically suggests that because there is so much online that we can consume, our attention is now a really valuable resource. And so to capture it, brands, companies, people, influencers now understand that that requires something really unique. In other words, like, we are less able to focus on one thing at a time or for a sustained amount of time. So you have to resort to something even more outlandish and even more attention-grabbing to bring people into the trend. And you really, like brands really want to push things to go viral so that longevity is no longer the goal.
It's why they're always looking for like the hottest new celebrity to face up their campaigns, always looking for like a real kind of gotcha moment or a big brand campaign that's just going to give them as much attention and eyes on their product as possible. Trends are nothing without that. The other thing that brands do that elevates our desire to buy micro trends is they make the shopping process really stressful to push us towards a purchase. So basically they make it so that everything feels like it's going to be urgent, the product is going to run out, the product's no longer going to be on sale, so that we buy it fast and we get the sense of relief that like, oh, great, that's off my to-do list. These are called dark patterns.
A 2019 study from Princeton actually cataloged some of these dark economic patterns in retail shopping. and here are some of the most common ones that you are going to see, especially like in fast fashion brands or really with any brand. So the first one is like urgency pushing. So if you obviously a countdown timer warning you that like a special offer is going to end in 60 seconds unless you that is a tactic. That is trying to stress you out. So you just try and remove the stress in the easiest way possible, which is to buy. There's also something called confirm shaming. So they'll offer you a discount and then you have to be like, no thanks. I'd rather pay full price if you decline. Like if you decline to sign up for like their email chain, which, you know,
inevitably makes you feel like, God, I've just lost money. I've lost money. But they want access to you. They know that if they can get you to sign up for their email chain, like they're going to make more money off of you, even if it means giving you a discount. And there's also these social proof tactics as well that we're seeing more often, which is like, Gemma from Australia just bought this purchase. Tom from America just saved a million dollars on this item using this discount code. Like those people aren't real, but this stresses you out. It gives you this social sense that like everybody else is in on this. Everybody else is doing this. And when we're stressed out, our prefrontal cortex is impeded. Our prefrontal cortex is responsible for rational decision
making. So when it's not able to send out those clarifying messages, emotion just takes over. And again, that lovely dopamine hit comes in to save the day. The company's social media has stressed you out, making you think that you're not going to be accepted. You're going to lose money. You're going to lose something if you don't buy it. So if you buy it, you get the relief. Over time, though, we know this. Like, it takes more. and more for you to receive the same level of pleasure from that dopamine or from that reward of buying something than it did before. That's why it's not just like the one t-shirt that you need. It's the t-shirt and the sweater and the sweater and the jeans. You know, it gets, you need
more and more to keep yourself satisfied. And that is why we are constantly wired to want more. Because more is good, right? That's what our brain thinks. More is good. That it's like the basis, the most primary basis of what we call hedonism or our reward system. It is our default. It is our default to want to collect and receive and buy more because back in the day when resources were scarce, that is how we survived. We survived by securing more for ourselves and securing more for our tribe. That's very scientific, lots of information being thrown at you there. How do we apply this to us in our 20s specifically?
here is how we apply it. Our 20s particularly are just chaotic. There's a lot going on. We all understand that. There's always like a fire that needs to be put out. And a big thing that's on fire is our sense of self, right? We don't really know who we are yet, even if we think we do. Microtrends, why they are so appealing during this decade, is because they provide a psychological sense of security, or safety through which we can reaffirm our identity. So essentially what I'm saying is that when you don't know who you are, when your boyfriend's broken up with you, when you don't really know what your dream job is, aligning yourself to what's in and hot and cool gives you a real confidence boost and provides you with a sense of like, well, at least I belong. At least I'm in the no. I really like the way that Terry Wu says it. He's a neuroscientist. He's an author. He runs the organization. why the brain follows. And he says the human brain is not a thinking machine that feels. It is a feeling machine that thinks. Humans have this innate desire. And again, whether you are in
your 20s or not, this innate desire to seize a sense of control. And if clothes, shopping, buying, gives you that, it is very hard to resist, especially during a period where you are already primed to feel chaotic and unsure, you know, it's only natural that shopping can become a coping mechanism. It can actually become an emotional regulator. We talked about this in our psychology of personal style episode. Remember that primal feeling we were talking about, like the desire to gather, collect, store, that kind of thing. That is what's going on here. We're literally like little chipmunks. We're these little squirrels, there's little chipmunks who want to gain more for ourselves and feel confident that we're going to have enough to survive the winter, that we're going to have
enough in our tank to feel confident, to feel secure, to feel safe, physically or emotionally. It's literally the same reason why, I don't know if you guys remember this. Of course you do. Like during COVID, everybody was buying toilet paper. Nobody needed that much toilet paper. This was a proxy for a sense of security and a sense of certainty. At this stage, you may be thinking like, okay, Gemma, so what? What is so bad about finding relief and joy through clothes and fashion and style during a really hard time for myself. Or like, what's so wrong with just experimenting? You know, why can't I just look good?
Why can't I just follow trends? Because, you know, what's so wrong with wanting to fit in? Honestly, in many ways, nothing. I have to agree with you. Like, probably nothing. However, what is important to know is that microtrens offer a false sense of hope. caring about clothes and feeling emotionally driven towards a trend that is not sustainable, like those are different things.
It's basically like I think micro trends are like a bad relationship that keep you hooked on potential. They basically give you the sense that like just one more, one more day, one more purchase and everything will finally be okay. He'll finally love me back. I'll finally feel good about myself. They give you the sense that there is always a newer, better version of you out there. They give you the hope that if I buy into this trend, I will finally feel like myself.
There is this destination that I will arrive at, I will arrive at in which I will finally be happy and in which I finally will belong and it is behind this next purchase. This has a name. It's aspirational buying. Essentially, it's aspirational thinking. It's fantasy thinking like in a relationship that makes us believe that purchases clothes, micro-trans, whatever, can fill an emotional hole in your life if you just buy enough. This is obviously not true because, again, a few months later, a few days later, the trend changes.
And the thing that we have staked our identity on suddenly becomes shaky again. And the new thing is in. Strawberry Girl, Tomato Woman, Mob husband, soft boy. it's not relevant anymore. So you're forced to go back to the drawing board. In an age where the drawing board is already very, very messy and a lot of us don't have the money to keep changing our identity every single season. So again, it's not that like caring about clothes is bad. It's just that this this pathway to caring about clothes is going to probably leave you feeling really anxious. It's also going to cost you a lot of money like I just mentioned. One British study from last year
estimated that it could cost you $250 a month on the low end of things to have a shopping addiction, to be attached to trends. And again, the less stable your identity is the younger you are, the more you are likely to spend if that is available to you. The more that you want to spend. I'm also of the firm belief, you know, buy it nice, buy it twice. And I just think that truly sitting down and intentionally choosing your style archetypes, labeling your style. Yeah, even if that changes over the years, does save you probably a lot of time. It does save you a lot of money. It saves you closet space and it saves you confusion about how you present and who you are right now.
And it seems like a lot more people are agreeing with that. That being intentional about clothes is the way to go. A lot of people are actually saying I was reading all these articles online that there is a very obvious decline in microch trends happening right now. Why is that? We're going to talk about that. And so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Paul. part. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really,
be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prices. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Okay, again, I've been going on and on about the psychology of microtrends and how they're bad for the environment, how they're bad for your bank account. And it turns out, microtrends are currently dying in very slow death. people are becoming more environmentally conscious, waste conscious. People are also kind of learning to, we've learned to anticipate the trend cycle that we've all seen. And we've kind of learned that they're not going to last very long. So more and more of us are riding out the wave of certain trends. I recently read an interesting Vogue article called Micro Trends Are Dead, Long Live the Vibe. And it talks about how online fashion discourse is changing.
in front of our very eyes because being trendy is no longer cool, being individual is. Personal expression, being anti-trend, that is emerging as a counterweight to the algorithm-driven micro-trend, online environment that we've been subjected to. People are tired of having to change who they are every five months to fit in with what other people are doing. People now want something, an aura, a vibe that trends cannot capture because it is so organic and natural, it cannot be repeated, just like our individuality and our identity in itself. I think it's also just because out, like, we're smart, right? Especially people in their 20s, but everybody, like humans are smart. They naturally notice patterns. And I think we've noticed the pattern of the micro trend enough now
to become suspicious of it and to recognize also when they're just clever marketing. being stunts. For example, I don't know if you guys remember this, I feel like this has come up a lot in this episode, the Mobwife Microtrend on TikTok, like all these people were accusing it of being an industry plant to tie to the re-release of the Sopranos in 2024. Like that's how people, like that's how companies and brands make things relevant. They tie it to a micro trend. In another article about this titled, Are Microtrends over? The authors of this article basically pointed to the fact that microtrendes, what really gave them an edge was the pandemic and was when everybody was at home and everybody lacked real life experiences. So things like were
transmitted very quickly online, trends flowed very quickly online. But now people are really leaning more towards being out and about. They are trying to consume less of less content and less of their identity online. And so they're no longer as relevant. Like it's just basically like we've recovered from the pandemic. The way that information spreads is different and micro trends aren't cool anymore because people are moving back to dressing for their real lives and dressing in a way that is unique and dressing in a way that doesn't signal being chronically online. because being chronically online in itself was a trend and it's now kind of going out of style. In other words, again, it pays to be individual.
It pays to have personal style. Having something that no one else can replicate is the trend. So my final thoughts on this actually are not my thoughts. They come from this fashion journalist called Ashanti Austin, who essentially says that this shift away from microtrends and to awards vibes. The reason it's happening is because a vibe doesn't require explicit markers. A vibe can encompass everything from culture to music, food, hobbies, history, background, all these things that cannot be copied. And considering that trends emerge in the first place for
self-expression and for individualism, why go the micro-trend route? what she basically says, and not to power phrase her words, but what I got from some of her writing is like, essentially, it's cliche. And it's not just cliche, but like, it is a form of rebellion to be like, I can see what you're trying to sell me. And I don't really care for it. And I don't really want to buy into this anymore. Like, I don't want to spend any more of my money being something that you are telling me is going to make me happy. And then you're going to take the rug out from under my feet, like the next moment. I want to be somebody who is firm in their values, firm in their personal style, and cannot be sold to. So here's a quick rapid fire of what you can do instead when you feel
the pool of a micro trend calling. And remember, like genuinely, sometimes things become micro trends, but also we just genuinely loved it beforehand. Or something becomes a micro trend. And to you, it's not a micro trend, right? To you, it is a core part of your. style, it's something that you really love. It's not to say that you can't buy into them. This is just how to be more conscious about it. The biggest thing is if you feel the desire to buy something, set it upon yourself to buy the best version of it, not just the first version of it that you see. I would also say if you are feeling like an emotional impulse to buy something, pause, examine where the emotional motivation is coming from.
and give yourself 24, 48 hours for that emotion, that motivational or motivating emotion towards the purchase to settle. What other dopamine avenues are available to you right now? What other ways can you get a sense of relief or happiness? Secondly, consider whether you are buying something because of the item or because of the lifestyle or emotion it is trying to sell you. Learn to recognize when the brand's budget has gone towards marketing and not to good craftsmanship or vice versa. Some of the longest wearing things I own are from brands that do not spend any money on big advertising campaigns or which are from op shops or depop or vinted because, you know, the objective there isn't to sell in great quantities or to sell as much as they can.
It's just to sell what they have on hand or what they think is good. There is a reason that the fashion and beauty industry is worth billions and billions of dollars every year. It is because marketers are so smart and they have found every single way to make you part with your money. Basically, if you can understand your identity and social psychology better than they do, you will not be manipulated by them into buying something just to feel like you need to belong. genuinely look at the company, look at what you want to buy, and do a bit of an analysis. How long is this actually going to last? And if I do think it's going to last, isn't it better to buy it quality?
I would also say keep an ongoing list in your phone of items you want to buy and how much they are. And then at the end of the month, yeah, you can buy them if you still want to, if you still want to, they're still in stock, if they're still on trend. but it would also give you, and it also does give you a really rich informational source for how much you are saving by not buying them. And I think it really, like a $20 purchase, a $50 purchase, a $5 purchase here and there, like you don't think about how much that is. But keeping track of what you want to buy or what you are buying monetarily is going to seriously shock you into how many of these techniques are working on you and whether you want them to work on you any long. Finally, a reminder for when you think, this item is the thing that's going to make me happy.
This item is the one. I want you to think of the happiest moment in your life. What were you wearing in that moment? And if you've been married, you can't use that example, because obviously wedding dress. But simple moments. What were you wearing? Can you remember that? Did it matter?
Did it really influence the moment that much? I really don't think it does. obviously clothes are a valuable and like super important part of self-expression. They're an art form, but they are not the be-all and end-all of happiness or social security or joy that you can look for. Like there are so many other alternatives. And at the end of the day, the thing that is going to matter the most to you is money spent on memories, money spent on experiences.
and like the memories that will form regardless of what you're wearing and regardless of whether you were trending or wearing the new it thing or not. So that is the end of this very preachy episode. Again, goes without saying you can do whatever you want really at the end of the day. Like you have autonomy and agency and if you like something, yeah, and you have the money. You can buy it if you would like. But I think this episode is just about giving you more of a conscious look into how brands and how algorithms are like directed to control you using your psychology and how they
deeply want you to part with your money and are in many ways like manipulating your neuroscience and your emotions and your cognition to get you to do so so yeah i found it super interesting to research this episode and to look into all these different processes i also want to thank our researcher lucy davidson for her help with this episode and for all the research and writing that she did, she is amazing. If you have made it this far, and you're a loyal listener, and you were listening on Spotify, I should say, leave a comment down below. What do you think is like the biggest micro trend of the moment? What do you think is the thing that you are looking around being like,
that is not going to last. That is going to be kaput in like a few weeks. I will go first. I think it's the deer print. I think we're going to see the death of deer print. And I also think we're going to see the death of like baby pink activeware. I don't know. Maybe not. You can disagree with me in the comments. But as always, make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening.
If this episode resonated with you, if you enjoyed it, please leave us a five-star review. Maybe send it to a friend who you think would also be interested so you guys can have a chat about it. But until next time, thank you again for joining us. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Rethink the next micro trend you see come across your feed. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier more fulfilled healthier person listen to 2% that's t w0% on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts on the look back at it podcast from 1979 that was a big moment for me 84's big to me i'm sam j and i'm alex english each episode we pick a here unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends fellow comedians and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional. who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Grega lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day. the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.